all right James Gandolfini Brad Pitt mob
movie death robbery there's no way this
movie's gonna bar me right that won't
happen
[Music]
killing them softly so killing them
softly is about a robbery that happens
then Brad Pitt's this hit man he gets
brought in by the higher-ups of the mob
and you never see them but you hear that
they're like hey Brad Pitt can you just
deal with the situation so now the
situation needs to be dealt with how
hitmen deal with situations and in that
we have this movie which is a very
realistic take on this situation I say
that because you know how realities
never is interesting is the movies like
you think being a police officer would
be exciting it's not that's kind of this
movie you see it you're like oh yeah if
this were a movie it would be more
exciting and more interesting to me only
thing is this is the movie about this
situation so it should be more
interesting than it comes across as I'll
talk about what I liked about this movie
there are a few things in this movie
that I did like first of all the acting
acting was out of this world it was
awesome Brad Pitt completely kills it as
his hit man he's really efficient you
get the feeling he's like the best of
the best in his field of work if you
have a really big problem involving a
couple of screw-ups that you know do a
robbery you bring in Brad Pitt even the
main two guys who did the robbery they
were really good one of them is the dude
from Argo I feel like you're gonna see
this guy in a lot more movies now this
was the movie where he's like hey not
only was I in Argo but I can show my
acting talent in this movie he'll get
more work does for sure the other guy is
Daggett from The Dark Knight Rises who
in this movie you're like well alright
this guy is a really good actor because
day it's all the upper class like where
does he get these guys then you see this
guy you're like holy [ __ ] Daggett what
happens like if Daggett in The Dark
Knight Rises lived long enough for
Bane's whole plan to come through and he
had to like live in the sewers and [ __ ]
he would look like Daggett in this movie
I'm gonna call him Daggett forever James
Gandolfini's in this movie and half of
me is like oh he did a really good job
the other half was like what was the
point of him being in this movie other
than just to say that James Gandolfini
was in this movie you just get to see a
guy who's at rock bottom but you can
argue that seeing him feeds into the
whole message of this movie this movie
has a really big message that the
director wants to get across I get that
but all in all it just felt like they
wanted James Gandolfini in this movie
right before the main robbery goes down
it had a couple of really funny moments
where I was like oh that's cool so
that's the kind of movie I'm in
but it wasn't the witty dialogue in the
humor ended right there I thought
there's going to be a total dialogue
movie and there's a lot of dialogue in
the movie but it doesn't feel like a
cool dialogue movie because none of its
really memorable I just don't think
people are going to be quoting killing
them softly five years from now they
will probably quote the end monologue by
Brad Pitt I get that I mean I like mob
movies I like dialogue based movies I
like dialogue based mob movies killing
them softly really didn't find its niche
because it just felt like it was all
over the place like he wanted to be this
now and then this now and then this now
like the director had a hundred and
fifty seven concepts and thoughts in his
mind for this movie he spread himself
too thin so none of them really shined
the actors really shine but that's
because they're good actors I get that
there's probably a demographic out there
who this movies made for them I'm not
that demographic and why you hipster
film students are going to love this
movie I actually have conversations with
myself about rating movies like this I'm
not like I mean it really it did have
good acting and that was cool and the
slow-mo scenes work oh my god stop it
just say it but say what's on your mind
the movie bored you so just say it I'll
illustrate that I don't want to come
across one of what come across as honest
I was gonna say an [ __ ] but well
there is one consistent in life
they're always seen as the same thing
anyway well there is that true the
majority of the movie were you bored for
the majority of the movie did the movie
bore you well yeah it was pretty boring
rest my case I hate it when I have a
point actually I like it
you mean when we have a point don't
worry they won't even think it's as
weird as you visioning your subconscious
and a leather jacket because that is
weird but ultimately killing them softly
there's one of these at least every year
is a two ative falls for those of you
who don't know what that is it means
it's a boring ass artsy movie that does
have its quality and its demographic but
it's just not mean it just ended up
boring me I will say it like this
I'm not even joking around I'm not even
bullshitting I'm not even trying to be a
smartass if you like the movie Drive you
might like this movie so take that into
consideration when you hear the rating
don't just go on the writing go on that
information also fact I'd be interested
to know if you liked drive and didn't
like this movie I would tell me I see
your favorite movie involving a hitman I
was gonna say mob movie I'm pretty sure
I've asked you that before but hitmen
it's kind of different it's a faction of
mob but not really the mob whatever your
favorite one has comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
you
[Music]